welcome back to gamespot stage here heat
3 2015 I am joined by the guys from
platinum games he hit to show
transformers devastation I beg could you
introduce yourselves please for the
stream absolutely so I'm Robert conky
producer at Activision this is kenji
site though he is the director from
platinum games and this is absolution
kadoka who is the producer from platinum
games welcome I think that let's start
with the surprise that everyone nobody
knew that you guys were working on a
transformers game how did it how did the
game come about um I think this is for
Caracas on so I know ma tfor Connelly no
big reader stuff for a toy out there Oh
No kohima god it's good either you're
anonymous Tarsonis oshawa uh no
Activision's on the ho paura and also it
the older very much there oh no ma so
you yogita to Tokra hazz metemma scared
o mo ano kum kimo ô subarashii a no
title no hace rato tika anathema little
idea anowar owari no score Joe Hockey
League Leona and I i peep at itt right
there are no he's only cars are similar
so it originally came from actually
exhibition so we worked with Hasbro and
we've done many a transformers game and
we we threw it their way and said you
know transformers buddy guy's got and
they had some really cool ideas and we
ended up working with them on it and
there they said there were super stoked
to be a war on such a cold cool over
Iran so see you guys we transform his
fans what is it like to work on such a
well established and famous franchise
sure I know jack transformers no fan
toast a transpose no game got square to
go to the metonic even the scar sodus a
boca para cada uno para cara de todo
sobre screechy boom Oh amo Saddam da
said I'll a anime vomited odd a perso
use a clinic a courier ma ma tote mo ba
s overspent on Oh Simon agra scripted
odo cinema Soto manado mata pero primero
de todo prestamo can save us
so he said it's kind of a mix of a
pressure and a lot of fun so he's been
playing with transformers nas's he was a
kid right it's it was right in his
generation so it meant a whole lot for
him to be able to do it but he does feel
like you know there's a lot of
expectation riding around it so there's
pressure there let's talk about like
there's a wider sort of legacy in Canon
when it comes to transformers because
you've got the like the old cartoons
you've got the comics you've got the new
gritty movies sure where are we pulling
from for transformers devastation sure
so I can answer that way so we've been
pulling from a multitude of places
actually so the key places that we're
pulling from our one the idw comic book
series they did a generation one reboot
they start in 2005 the generations toy
line from Hasbro app as well as of
course the original TV show all these
kind of put together into one modern
package to kind of pay homage to the
rich history of transformers sure I mean
the visuals as well because he it kind
of retains the comic book look sure the
cartoon look but it also has sort of
like cell shading as well exactly was
that a deliberate decision it was yes
that's exactly what they were going for
and if you want I can talk about it all
day if you want yeah I deauxma how do
you know comic books at all I don't I
need me any skype me that means I latest
uh oh no sorry got yo yo honey right
about the captain of the ship captain so
this name at all it's not social center
shading today hey the cross whole lot
put them in a cat Oh Papa Davy Jones on
over i'll get on the schedule mah cell
shading with a runner aboard a tiny
Konami dementia light Oh Papa unison i
do wat da de veau follow me Tommy they
did I Coco so when when we first brought
it when a collision first product then
we said hey we can like see what you
guys can do a cell shading and they said
yo week you've got if we want to use
self trading it has to look like this
right like this is the way is the only
way you could imagine it going so also
talking about the combat we can see here
transform I mean that's the thing with
transform is absolutely um how is it are
we able to use that in combat and to get
around the city
so there's actually three key ways that
well I guess you could say for there's
four key ways that transformation is
being used so one is the way that you
often see it in in a lot of games it's
used for mobility to get around but
there are three unique ways that are in
this game that you never really seen
before so one is you can use it to
connect combos so when they're when
you'll see the character fighting and
there'll be like little blue sparkle
whenever that happens it's an
opportunity to use what we're calling a
vehicle attack turn into a vehicle you
jump after them and continue your combo
if you're good you can do that multiple
times in a row and actually change super
long super crazy combos the other ways
actually used offensively so you can use
transformation to dodge attacks if you
hold the button you'll actually turn
into a vehicle after you dodge and then
the last one is what we're calling rush
attacks where if you build up maximum
speed as your as your if you build it
back to meet as a vehicle and then you
attack to unleash a really really
powerful combo so so not only within the
wider transformers law I guess and on
universe where other inspirations have
you drawn from especially when it comes
to game player me because there's so
many ways you can tackle sure
transformers game but I me like tomorrow
he went to see the game yesterday said
that um there was a little bit that
reminded him of Bayonetta because if you
dodge correctly you can get like which
time don't like it it's like you know
time slows is that was that a conscious
decision yeah um I know my conch I our
focus car enjoy sky high I don't mind I
know pianeta Nicolini time on this go I
don't Matsuri oh it's good to go you
know console myself oh no they say be
honest a donut I own up to you come up
so no need to be to you baka dawa last
echo coyote apt bar solo throat oh you
to follow up and hung geeky cool geeky
no chance for you to bro no Middle East
Oct ademas de onate anakin solo game of
design ptosis Roku me Coco Co Tony Otero
a chance time money not even days okay
coca tea guy me optimism so he said
there's a very large difference between
the way that that work and being at
engineer so here it's really more about
once you've done that dodge it's an
opportunity to do a counter-attack that
actually leads directly into it into a
vehicle attack now as opposed to
Bayonetta where it was more of a
really big chance to land a bunch of
combos so while the base is the same the
actual practice it's it's much different
so let's talk a little bit about the
story then because they might announce
transformers funds it's an amazing
opportunity to be able to imprint your
own like legacy sure uh where did the
idea come from what so we are actually
working with Andy Schmidt who is a
writer for of the ITU w comic series he
works prominently on all hail Megatron
which was a really popular portion of
that and he's also working with us on
previous games war for cybertron fall of
cybertron and res the dark spark so he's
been an incredible asset and we managed
to put it was actually a collaboration
between all of us because we needed to
match gameplay but we also needed it to
tell a cool story and so we worked with
these guys very closely and managed to
get to where we are but it is said in
the generations universe and if you want
to give you the summary please ok so the
overall summary is the Decepticons
arrive on earth and it appears that
Earth has been is being forcibly and
violently transformed into a new
Cybertron and it much it to the expense
of everyone living there so it's pretty
destructive and so the Decepticons seem
to know what's going on and that
Autobots don't really understand it yet
they end up finding this ship that's
underground that seems to be the source
of it and the Decepticons get there
first and the Autobots have to stop them
so that's kind of what happens there any
times the famous of fate for metal faces
I suppose they were tasty in the game so
either bumblebee Optimus Prime who is
the most fun to kind of play around with
and inject life into oh well that's
definitely a matter of opinion but yeah
let's see what they say I don't hey punk
i no give it a while it's gone up way up
it or not i oughtta go you know Mon this
get all I know it's Colonel guy you see
one time she kept the whole let's do
this your car you think about a
palladium go oh no I I know Mom you're
talking about specifically about the
playable character so you're talking
about all the courage I mean or at least
yeah I mean because I've been amazing
characters than that right and I much
that pulled from all over oh yeah yeah
um okay Joe
yeah podría Bruno kiara no a prayer
brownie can i buy apple ibook ooh goodie
broker when he have with us a dice que
ella de soto criminal quilt screwed over
a pan panos catteries takia pre-k Oh
Nina ready Toto top Cena 80 pro bono de
mussoorie oh y Castillejo spooked a mi
ropa tata motors company so his favorite
design was actually Grimlock because
he's always a cool dinosaur obviously
but he also is very unique in that he
doesn't turn into a vehicle he turns
into a dinosaur and that really changes
things and way that you approach the
game so just from a character standpoint
as well as a very different gameplay
style standpoint it was incredibly
interesting for him wonderful gentleman
thank you so much for joining me best of
luck transformers devastation when can
we play it this fall this year wonderful
so not long to wait at all no guys make
sure you don't go anywhere more awesome
game demos coming right up here on the
games with stage